how do you know he spoke Aramaic because
that's what they that's what he spoke
it's a it's a known uh it's a known fact
everyone knows that Jesus spoke Aramaic
in his time where he was according to
the people because according to how wait
how do you know what how do you know he
spoke Aramaic how do you know what time
he lived in oh because in The Passion of
the Christ he was speaking Aramaic so I
don't know you're talking about the
movie yeah yeah so the okay so the movie
is is correct on the life of Jesus is is
the movie wrong I mean about Lang
is the is the movie correct in the life
of Jesus not the crucifixion part oh so
then I guess we're taking the movie out
so here we go again how do you know that
Jesus spoke Aramaic because he said Kesh
and Muslim how do you know spoke ar your
your Quran doesn't say that so where
does he how do you know that hey yo
what's up you good good yeah I'm good
I'm good okay so I I wanna I want to
talk about what you talked about what
you talked to this guy about
yeah yeah yeah I'm I'm also Muslim all
right how would you prove that yeah he's
he is a Muslim how would you prove that
by the Quran the Quran is just a claim
I'm challenging the yeah yeah yeah but
but listen but listen for example you
you cannot prove to me some things that
are in the Bible but you you believe in
it because the Bible says it right no I
believe it because I have proof of it no
but you cannot believe some some of the
things in the Bible you cannot prove
yeah I can but Yeah Yeah by your logic
of course but by my logic he isn't a
Christian no there is so so so we have
to use we have to use we have to use a
different standard because for me for me
the Quran is sufficient
what yeah I'm not I'm not talking about
subjective so I'm asking for proof um it
doesn't matter if I'm a Christian or
you're a Muslim proof is proof right
Allah said so listen I me as a Muslim I
don't I don't need more proof than God
saying it is so that's fine for you
that's not proof though that's just a
claim that's you that's a claim that you
that that God said that it's a claim
that he said that in the Quran of the
it's called circular reasoning prove to
me that Jesus is a Muslim the Quran says
he's a Muslim how do you know the Quran
is is telling is right about it because
good good good God now we're getting
somewhere now how do God says it because
the Quran says it you see that circular
reasoning okay okay okay but now we're
getting somewhere could you prove to me
that the Bible is 100% true I can prove
to you that you rely on the Bible no no
no no no no no could you prove to me
that's not the
question I asked the question that's
straightforward could you prove to me
that the Bible is true yes I can I can
do that okay this this is what I need
ebo yes I either need you to prove prove
to me that Jesus was a Muslim or say I
can't prove it it's just a belief that I
have no my my proof is because God said
it so but then but then after that we we
can go into the claim of which book is
actually right we can judge the book for
example if I ask you how did Judas die
they asked for him to come up there's no
way they asked for him to come up I'm
only letting Muslims up guys so if
you're not Muslim please don't request
there's no way they asked him to come up
hey Johnny how you doing you're Muslim
alhamdulillah all right right right
right Hey so uh have you ever uh uh read
Matthew I believe it's uh 16 no I'm
sorry yeah Matthew 16 27-28 or is it
Matthew 6 27 through 28 what does it say
it says okay so it's 16 it's 16 all
right loading all right there it is okay
so 27 uh for the son of man is going to
come in his father's Glory with his
angels uh and then he will reward each
person according to what they have done
28 truly I tell you some who are
standing here will not taste death
before they see the son of man coming in
his kingdom now this is speaking of
Jesus's Second Coming are we on the same
page yeah how does this prove that he's
a mus cool cool cool um does this how
does this prove that he's a Muslim I'm
I'm getting there if you just you know
if you can eat your corn flakes and just
listen to me no no just making sure like
so this has this has straight to do with
him being a Muslim right yeah that's
that's where we're going to get to okay
yep um so have have his disciples tasted
death what does it have to do what does
it have to do with him being a Muslim
I'm gonna get there do you want to
answer my question or just I want you to
answer the question on the topic how
does this prove that he's a Muslim or
not well we're going to start off by uh
showing you that your book has false
prophecies and it is unreliable
after that I'm going to take you to
another verse that has nothing to do
with my topic prove okay as I said I'm
going to show you that your book is
corrupted that's going to cancel that
out here's going to be what's going to
happen you're G to show me that Jesus is
a Muslim that's what you're going to
start off with and then you can go into
other subjects once the Jesus as a
Muslim topic is done we could talk about
your objections to the Bible or whatever
gotcha gotcha gotcha okay well uh Jesus
walked around uh telling people KES and
Muslim uh do you know what that means
nope all right all right well that's
Aramaic uh it means submit your will uh
to the one God wait how do you know he
spoke Aramaic because that's what they
that's what he spoke it's a it's a known
uh it's a known fact everyone knows that
Jesus spoke Aramaic in his time where he
was according to the people because
according to how wait how do you know
what how do you know he spoke Aramaic
how do you know what time he lived in oh
because in The Passion of the Christ he
was speaking Aramaic so I don't know
you're talking about the movie yeah yeah
so okay so the movie is is correct on
the life of Jesus is is the movie wrong
I mean about language spoke is the is
the movie correct in the life of Jesus
not the crucifixion part oh so then I
guess we're taking the movie out so here
we go again how do you know that Jesus
spoke Aramaic because he said Kesh and
Muslim how do you know aric your your
Quran doesn't say that so where does he
how do you know that are you saying he
didn't speak Aramaic I'm asking you how
do you know that it's just a known fact
that every Everybody Knows saying it's a
known fact doesn't tell me how it's a
known how do you know that this is a
fact well I can't prove it to you
because uh the oldest gospels were in
Greek and um and they were written by
people who never you know never met
Jesus they're just Anonymous books from
so where do you get this from that Jesus
spoke Aramaic just learning history and
learning things from people what history
tells you that Jesus spoke Aramaic
what's their Source a Stephan L Harris
Christian scholar what's his Source oh a
Christian scholar who says that Jesus
was crucified interesting so what is the
source Stephan L Harris explains to
everybody that Jesus spoke Aramaic in
that time his Source the people in that
time spoke Hebrew and Aramaic what is
his Source his Source I I don't know
okay so that still doesn't ask my
question how do you know he spoke
Aramaic so I'm going do it one more time
time I believe you're a smart guy if you
can just answer my question or you can
humbly admit the answer to the question
which you don't want to say or just say
man I don't know so let me just take
that out then how do you know that Jesus
spoke aric how do I know that Jesus
spoke Aramaic is because I was just
taught that from the world around me so
you don't know that then huh I I was not
in that time to physically video what do
you mean that time what time I wasn't
walking in the time of Jesus to
physically record him speaking what time
was that that was uh 108 not 10 ad but
how do you know that how do you know
that it was about 2,000 years ago to be
exact how do you know that how do I know
that yeah how do I know that he lived
2,000 years ago is that your question
I'm confused yeah how do you know how do
you know he was walking around in 108
because according to the Quran uh Allah
sent uh Jesus with the NG to the
children of Israel what time though the
of Israel have been living for
generations and centuries I you know I
don't think the Quran mentions a time
but uh don't don't appeal to the Quran
then the Quran doesn't tell you this how
do you know walking around in the first
century in 10 the Quran is a Guide to
Life it's not like a a history lesson it
ain't guiding you to this how do you
know how do you know Jesus was walking
around in 2,000 years ago because I know
I I believe Jesus existed I believe he
was a prophet and a messenger how do you
know when he existed I don't care about
you believing he was a prophet I respect
that okay because the Christians said he
was walking around 2,000 years ago
Christians also say that the Christians
also say Jew don't believe he walked at
all they also say he was crucified they
also say that Matthew Mark Luke and John
are the ones who wrote the Gospel so you
notice how you're relying on Christians
on the information that you get about
Jesus yet you're trying to neglect and
reject what Christians say in totality
do you see how you're caught I just told
you some things are reliable and some
things are corrupted like fre
how do you know that it's that they're
that they're unreliable when it comes to
the language Jesus spoke and the time he
was walking him how do you know that
that part is reliable but the other
parts aren't because it specifically
says in the Quan nor was he crucified
where in the Quran does it say he spoke
Aramaic and was walking around in the
first century the Quran doesn't say he
spoke Aramaic how do you know so how do
you know that they are reliable years
ago in Bethlehem they spoke Hebrew and
Aramaic how do you know this how do you
even know about Bethlehem you know
there's been Palestinians living in
Bethlehem for the last 1500 years right
how do you know that Jesus was in
Bethlehem bro like I don't know what you
want me to do you want me to print out
birth certificates and social security
cards like do what I want you to do
Billy is I want you to tell me the truth
I want you to tell me the truth I'm
telling okay so you know you know the
answer to this you just you want me to
say look look look you're a cool dude
bro you're you're I'm not I'm not I'm
not uh uh I don't hate you bro or none
of that I'm just trying to say I'm just
trying to say something bro do you me do
you believe he didn't speak a mic it's
not about my belief that's not what I
asked you there he goes in his mode yeah
I'm in my mode man he just he just he
just pushed the button he just pushed
the red button hold on hold on I just I
just pushed the button hold on man you
just you bring it hold on a
seconde it man I wasn't even going I
wasn't even gonna go in this mode look
at him look at him he putting on the
whole
shebang I wasn't even gonna go in this
that's it the apron's on gonna do it the
apron's on but you made me bring it out
why the apron on man why you Mak me
bring this out big dog everybody bro
everybody for cover bro I was I wasn't
even thinking about this man oh he
put on the he put on the I wasn't even
thinking about this dog he put on the
Fresh Prince muff look oh man he he
going now for some reason you wanted to
pull this out of me I try to be cool I
try to be cool man oh man oh man here we
are again how do you know that Jesus
lived in the first century and lived in
Bethlehem and spoke Aramaic how do you
know this you know the answer but you
don't want to say it just be honest and
say the right I told you bro from from
Christian Scholars and your Bible bro
where did they get there it is from the
Bible the same Bible that you just tried
to start off with by discrediting and
saying that it's corrupted and unrel I'm
not trying to discredit man I'm just
trying to get an explanation of why
Jesus well the Jesus that you see how
you relying on the Bible you see that
again I'm not relying man I'm just
showing you that um there's a prophecy
stated in there that that didn't happen
man I mean that should ring alarms no
you rely on the Bible do you not see how
you rely on the Bible for what you know
about Jesus brother I rely on history
and the history comes from where comes
from the Bible comes from the Torah
comes from many things bro comes from
the Quan so what you know about Jesus
historically as your historical
Authority is the Bible yet you're trying
to say that the Bible is corrupted and
reliable yet you're using it as your
historical Authority on the life of
Jesus brother if if I use anything else
you're not gonna you're not going to
believe it you're gonna say no it's it's
it's void no it's not it's not that show
me another primary source give me
something other than the Bible then
that's a primary source in the life of
Jesus that tells you that he spoke
Aramaic lived 2,000 years ago walked
around lived in Bethlehem for a time at
some point yeah man there there isn't
there isn't you know there isn't I know
so what you're calling history and
relying on as a historical reliability
historical Authority is the Bible the
same source that you're saying is
corrupted and that you don't believe in
it that thinking makes no sense to me so
does it I mean does it make sense to to
say that uh to tell the disciples that
before they taste death they're going to
see a second coming and then it not
happening I mean that doesn't ring an
alarm bro not even willing to deal with
this you're not even willing to deal
with this I promise you we you can get
you can bring up your objections to the
Bible all you want once we finish this
just finish this we can go we can go
straight to that we can go straight to
that just finish this please how do you
want me to finish it I mean I want you
to finish it with
honesty I told you a lot of the history
is from you know it's from the Bible but
a lot of things are right and a lot of
things are wrong bro I just gave you an
example of wrong so so it it's it's
reliable and correct when it comes to
the to what Jesus did how he lived and
what he said right brother is is
everything reliable on CNN news this
ain't CNN news this is the Bible this is
a primary source in the life of Jesus is
it not brother is everything reliable in
the Torah yeah really so you have to
keep the Commandments I keep the
Commandments of the Messiah now I don't
have to follow the laws okay bro so that
doesn't mean that those laws were not
reli it's there logic logic logic are
you saying are you saying God are you
saying God made a mistake by giving us
the Commandments thinking we can handle
it when we couldn't you able to answer
man are you able to answer answer what
brother take care man and you come up
the way that you do that's what happens
man you get humbled when you come up the
way that you do you get humbled if you
come straight humble you won't have to
get humbled you know if you come humble
you won't have to get humbled but then
you had to get humbled